the owner of the nfl's washington
commanders has been subpoenaed for
questioning by a congressional committee
dan snyder has refused to discuss an
alleged workplace misconduct and sexual
harassment in the commander's
organization nicole killian is on
capitol hill where she covered a hearing
on this yesterday nicole good morning
hey good morning to you nate and the
house oversight committee is giving dan
snyder until next week to appear for a
deposition after he failed to show up
for yesterday's hearing because he was
out of the country his spokesperson
dismissed it as a politically charged
show trial
that was my goal and my dream growing up
was to be a red skinnette and
you know unfortunately dan snyder
took that passion out of my dream a
deflated dream from melanie coburn who
spent 14 years as a cheerleader and
marketing executive for the then
washington redskins now known as the
commanders what would you say was the
worst part of your experience the sexual
harassment at every turn i've been in
very dangerous situations where you know
there's been drinking encouraged
describing a toxic culture the house
oversight committee released a 29-page
memo alleging owner dan snyder launched
a shadow investigation creating a
dossier to discredit his accusers it
also found the nfl allowed him to
investigate his own team and influence
an independent investigation into
misconduct which has not been released
if the nfl is unwilling or unable to
hold mr snyder accountable
then i am prepared to do so nfl
commissioner roger goodell would not
commit to releasing its internal report
but told lawmakers the team was fined 10
million dollars and has made reforms we
have been open and direct about the fact
that the workplace culture at the
commanders was not only unprofessional
but toxic for far too long he was
pressed about further action against
snyder will you remove him
i don't have the authority to remove him
according to the nfl bylaws and
constitution the commissioner does have
the authority to refer disciplinary
issues to the league's executive
committee at least 24 of the 32 team
owners would need to vote to remove an
owner what do you want to see come out
of this process i want transparency so
there can be true accountability
snyder has denied the allegations
against him calling them outright lies
commanders head coach ron rivera
defended the team in a tweet writing i
cannot change the past but i would hope
that our fans the nfl and congress can
see that we are doing everything in our
power to never repeat those workplace
issues tony
all right nicole thank you very much